avril 1969 à orléans sans internet ni
les réseaux sociaux une rumeur se répand
dans la ville
une camarade de plasma verte et en me
disant tu sais voilà ce qui se passe à
orléans des magasins sont incriminés
dans la traite des blanches à nous a dit
surtout je vous dis ça uniquement pour
que vous n'alliez pas tout seul
des femmes disparaîtrait dans des
cabines d'essayage de magasins de
lingerie tenus par des juifs droguée
elle serait ensuite emmené jusqu'à des
sous-marins caché dans la loire pour
rejoindre des réseaux de prostitution à
l'étranger un scénario ubuesque auquel
beaucoup ont cru j'étais dans les
autobus ch était dans les magasins c'est
partout on en parlait 1 terrasse des
cafés partout partout partout partout on
en parlait et plus on en parlait plus ça
prenait forme de vérité quoi pourtant la
police est formel aucune disparition de
femme n'a été signalé pendant cette
période la rumeur d'orléans prend alors
une tournure antisémites et nous
trouvions devant une véritable cavale
pendant deux mois entre avril et juin
1969 les commerces visés sont désertés
par les clients certains commerçants
juifs sont même insultés et menacés
certains jeunes les commerçants porte
plainte et alertent l'opinion publique
sur la calomnie dont ils sont victimes
la rumeur d'orléans interpelle
journalistes et intellectuels
le sociologue edgar morin théorise alors
le processus de la rumeur et
l'acharnement subies par les commerçants
juifs
le fantôme du juive qui dans le monde de
chrétien occidental est celui qui fixe
une angoisse qui prend en charge la
culpabilité est finalement qu on va
sacrifier comme bouc émissaire ce
fantôme du juif commencent à sortir des
profondeurs où on le croyait à jamais un
flux
après le sociologue la modernité de ces
commerces représentaient aussi une
inquiétude pour certains par et pour eux
c'est l'occasion de dire leur joie et
crié vous voyez mes enfants faites
attention
on commence par la minijupe l'on ne sait
pas où ça peut conduire à orléans la
rumeur s'éteindra au bout de deux mois
en juin 1969 mais 21 ans plus tard cette
commerçante visait à l'époque ne se
faisait pas trop d'illusions il est
toujours très difficile de faire
complètement disparaître toute trace de
la rumeur savais que ça s'est vérifié
pendant des siècles elle laisse toujours
un petit poisson derrière elle
[Musique]